und es geht wieder ab ins all heute
starten vier weltraumtouristen zur iss
inklusive zehn tagen aufenthalt in der
raumstation
da bin ich auch ein bisschen neidisch
mallorca würde ich machen aber alles
esse und blick von oben auf wirklich
auch der lift auf der space ex rakete
falcon 9 ist geplant für 17 uhr 17 los
geht's auf dem weltraumbahnhof cape
canaveral in florida und es wird der
nächste schritt in sachen
weltraumtourismus
ein ticket zur iss bitte hin und zurück
wenn es geht der weltraumtourismus
zündet die nächste antriebs stufe die
zur internationalen raumstation für
weltraum touristen sollen heute mit dem
texanischen startup-unternehmen axiom
zur iss fliegen
seit ich vor zehn jahren die nasa
verlassen habe bin ich ein großer
verfechter und glaube fest an
kommerzielle flüge in den weltraum
[Musik]
weltraumtourist mit ihm ging es los am
11 juli letzten jahres fliegt multi
milliardär richard branson mit seinem
raketenflugzeug wie ss unity ins all
vier minuten schwerelosigkeit über der
wüste von new mexico
86 kilometer über der erde
an die nächste generation der träumer
wenn wir das hier schaffen stellt euch
vor was wir schaffen könnte
[Applaus]
nur neun tage später dies der zweite
multimilliardär ins weltall jeff bezos
der gründer von amazon hat das weltraum
rennen gegen bremsen zwar verloren die
new shepherd kapsel von blue origin hat
aber rekorde an bord den jüngsten und
ältesten weltraumtouristen aller zeiten
den 18 jährigen investmentbanker sohn
oliver damon und die 82-jährige rolli
funk weltraum pionieren der ersten
stunde
wir werden eine straße zum weltraum
bauen damit unsere kinder und deren
kinder die zukunft gestalten können wir
müssen das tun um die probleme hier auf
der erde zu lösen
bienia b sus captain kirk fliegt zu den
sternen am 13 oktober heben star trek
legende william shatner und drei weitere
weltraumtouristen ab ins all the source
blue origin bringt die tories in 106
kilometer höhe shatner schnappt mit
seinen 90 jahren wally frank dem titel
des ältesten weltraumtouristen weg am 9
dezember düsen zwei japanische
multimilliardäre mit einer sojus-kapsel
bereits zur iss filmproduzent casarano
und mode tycoon user kuma war
sie bleiben sogar mehrere tage in der
raumstation
jetzt soll mit der axxe um die erste
tour emission von spacex zur iss düsen
geplant ist ein 10 tägiger aufenthalt
diesmal geht es offiziell um die erste
komplett private crew die vier männer
sollen wissenschaftlich im weltraum
arbeiten
marginale unterschiede auf der jagd nach
rekorden es wird voll auf der iss